all of your beliefs are held in your
subconscious mind to create anything you
are using your subconscious mind so now
to manifest you have to believe and you
have to believe that you already have
whatever it is that you want and the
reason that you have to believe you have
it already is because the subconscious
mind is only operating in the present it
can't reason it's just like a program so
if you say for example a new car is
coming my new car is coming I'm going to
get a new car it's coming well then it's
always going to be coming right you have
to imagine you have it now you have to
go off and you have to test drive the
car you've got to feel the car smell the
car and just then visualize being in
that car and then when you do that
that's how you'll come to believe that
you actually have the car and the moment
that you believe there's manifestations
instantaneous hey it's Evan Carl Michael
and I make these videos because of my
first business I struggled to stay
afloat I quited my business partner and
the thing that kept me going was
studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how to quickly
activate the Law of Attraction enjoy
so the other ways to believe is to
affirm over and over and over
um so to be really repetitive for
example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful because when we
close our eyes and we put ourselves in
the picture and you must make sure
you're in the picture and you put
yourself in the picture with whatever it
is that you want and you close your eyes
and you just kind of create this mini
movie honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea it just
sees that movie and recreates it it's
like a giant photocopying machine it
will just whatever you hold in your mind
it will photocopy it won't into the
world so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if and for example if you wanted
to attract a perfect partner are you
acting as if your perfect partner's here
already and so there are just small
things that you can do that are super
super powerful for example are you
sleeping in the middle of your bed or
are you sleeping on one side of the bed
because your partner's on the other side
of the bed do you have room in your
wardrobe for your perfect partner's
clothes is there room in your bathroom
for their toothbrush and for their
things and so you see they are just
little things you can set the table for
two you don't have to put food on the
plate but just setting the table for two
is really really powerful it's saying my
perfect partner's here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it and
your perfect partner will be attracted
to you through the most incredible
circumstances so
um if something hasn't manifested yet
and you really really want it and I I
doubt there's anybody out there who's
who wants something and it hasn't
manifested right I mean
um I'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it
that's the reason you have a belief that
you don't have it
that's it and so all it's just a
programming subconscious mind it's
really easy just to affirm over and over
and over now to make your subconscious
mind believe that all of the things that
I've just talked about are really clever
I remember them all let me tell you
about what I did with the secret because
that's a big manifestation right and it
wasn't just me it was an amazing secret
team and we all used to gather at 11
o'clock each day and have a meeting and
we would all visualize the sacred green
joy to millions of people around the
world
I basically affirmed and visualized and
affirmed and visualized over and over
and over and over and over with almost
every single footstep that I took it was
so important to me and look what
happened with the secret in the world so
you know if if that can be done with a
bunch of Australians which is what we
are
then you can you can create anything you
really can
um so
your subconscious mind is
like your pot of gold it's your Midas
Touch Your Holy Grail your superpower
Atomic superpower and it will create
anything and everything that it believes
so whether it's a body that needs to
heal itself whether it's attracting new
relationships wanting to manifest a
house family passing exams getting into
college getting your dream job a
promotion a pay rise
trip a World trip a new car you name it
everything is possible
which is what this talk is about today
so if you want to understand more about
your mind and the subconscious mind and
I would really urge you because the more
that you understand the less control it
has over you and the more control you
have over it
I wrote about it at the subconscious
mind and the mind extensively in the
greatest secret because it is so so
important it's what is dictating our
whole life experience every single
second not just the things we're
deliberately uh deliberately creating
but it's also creating every moment like
you attracted this moment being here on
this talk right now so every single
second we're creating them all so it's
good to create just the ones that the
things that you really want in life and
that means that
you only want to empower thoughts of
what you want and you don't want to take
any notice of the thoughts of what you
don't want so if you've got a whole lot
of doubtful thoughts you're like what do
I do about the doubtful thoughts guess
what I don't believe it rule number two
is commit to your goals with Marissa
Pierre here's something that happens
when you do something to make your goal
real something happens something shifts
so my story very quickly is that I
always wanted to write but I wasn't sure
I could and then I wrote an article for
my daughter's school paper that was
really easy everybody loved it I decided
to write a book I went to an event
sitting next to a girl we were talking
and she told me she was a publisher the
penguin
and she gave me her car but then she
happened to say that she was moving to
Hong Kong in six weeks so I took her car
to put it in my bag
and six weeks when I knew she'd left I
called her number and asked him they
said she's not she's left I went oh she
asked me to send my book dropped and
went really I said oh yes I've got her
card here and she asked me to send my
book they went okay we'll look Sandy but
you must write on it this is not an
answered manuscript because if you don't
we won't open it so I sent it to them I
sent it to lots of other Publishers too
I took that risk you see
someone put me in front of that woman
the universe conspired as I took the
courage to write my book The Universe
put me next to a publisher and then I
went to a dinner party I met an agent
and one of my clients said well you know
the best agent in town he's your client
I'm like really they went yeah and I
went oh and I called him he came to me
he was my client I treated him for
depression long ago and he became my
angels I didn't need an agent I've got a
book deal already because penguin took
my book he said I will get you five
times what they're offering you and he
did
all these things happened all these
unforeseen events came out because of my
commitment to do something the minute
you commit
to something to your goal book write it
read it touch it the minute you commit
to it the universe works with you all
kinds of unforeseen amazing things will
be put in your way right in front of
because
you committed everything will fall into
place rule number three is release your
negative beliefs with Gabby Bernstein
everyone has unresolved areas where they
are out of alignment due to their
upbringing their belief systems from
childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted so some people might be
Health some people might be sex some
people it might be money some people it
might be their worth some people might
be all of the above whatever we've all
got it we've all got an area or many
where we are misaligned with the feeling
of love and abundance and and Grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are doing anything wrong
it's that you are your awareness of it
is actually major okay so the undoing of
the lack mentality is a journey of
clearing the belief systems from a
experiential time in your life right
that happens once again through books
like the universe has your back so
fantastic that you're doing that
transform fear to Faith excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural Pathways from the
experiences that we've had as children
particularly young childhood experiences
but the good news is thanks to
neuroplasticity our brain actually can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our PTSD can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new Behavior so one thing that you can
do simply In This Moment is to notice
when you are in that lack mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method I've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes I could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy whichever one I hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but what you can do
for yourself you're here for self-help
you're here for Gabby to tell me how I
can serve myself you can be in the
proactive development of new thought
patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack Story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel step two forgive
yourself for having the thought it's
very simple up there is my childhood
story there's my parents lack story
again up there it is again all right I
forgive myself it just showed up again
because that forgiveness will dissolve
that guilt and tension and fear that
you're manifesting it all that crap
right third step choose the next best
feeling thought choose the thought of
you know what I just forgave myself for
that thought so I'm dissolving it in
this moment I actually am listening to
the universe has your back and it's so
supportive then I can actually go and
listen to Super attractor so you can go
from thought to thought to thought to
reach for the next best feeling thought
and by the way isn't that an abundant
moment I just gave you something
so your willingness to face this lack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you right and
especially if you're feeling afraid that
you're manifesting things because you're
having the thoughts then just forgive
the thoughts because or forgive yourself
for having the thought because the
moment that you say oh I forgive myself
for that thought or I forgive that
thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized I am not that
thought it's just a thought that I keep
thinking I am not that belief it's just
a thought that I keep thinking also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is create
effective affirmations with Jack
Canfield today I want to explain why you
need a daily affirmation practice in
order to open yourself up to receive all
the things you want to deserve and
ultimately live a happier and more
fulfilling life successful people from
Top sales people and entrepreneurs to
best-selling authors and Olympic
athletes have figured out that using
willpower to power this Success is Not
Enough you need to let go of any and all
negative thoughts and images and bombard
your subconscious mind with new thoughts
and images that are positive and stated
in the present tense
and the technique you use to do this is
called affirmations which is simply a
statement that describes a goal in its
already completed state
two examples would be I am joyfully
walking across the stage as I receive my
MBA degree from the word and Business
School
or I'm so happy and grateful that I'm
now crossing the finish line of the
Boston Marathon in addition to all of
the feedback I've received from hundreds
of thousands of students from around the
world about the effectiveness of their
having used affirmations there is now
new academic research that shows in high
stress level environments those who do
daily affirmations have lower stress
levels and more success than those who
don't repeating affirmations daily helps
to reprogram the unconscious mind for
Success it helps eliminate negative and
limiting beliefs and transforms your
comfort zone from a limited one keeping
you trapped in mediocrity to a more
expanded one where anything is possible
it also helps you replace your I can't
with thy cans and your fears and doubts
with confidence and certainty
affirmations are daily reminders to your
unconscious mind to stay focused on your
goals and to come up with solutions to
challenges and obstacles that might get
in the way
affirmations also can create a higher
vibration of happiness joy appreciation
and gratitude that then through the Law
of Attraction magnetize people resources
and opportunities to come to you to help
you achieve your goals
now whether you know it or not you are
always using affirmations but usually
not towards that will bring you what you
want things like everything I eat go
straight to my hips
I'm never going to be able to meet
someone I can love I never catch a break
no matter what I do I never seem to get
ahead the daily use of affirmations
interrupts and eventually totally
replaces this barrage of negative
thoughts and beliefs
to achieve this you must continually
flood your unconscious with thoughts and
images of the new reality you wish to
create
now I'm going to share with you two sets
of guidelines for creating powerful
affirmations of work the long form and a
short form they both work though I
prefer the longer form
first here's the eight guidelines for
the long form for creating effective
affirmations you may want to write these
down they're also in my book the success
principles
number one start with the words I am
these are the two most powerful words in
the English language
number two always use the present tense
number three stated in the positive
affirm what you do want not what you
don't want number four keep it brief so
the subconscious mind can remember it
number five make it specific don't just
say a car say a red Porsche Carrera 911
whatever number six include an action
word ending with ing I am acting I'm
walking across the stage I'm depositing
my check ETC number seven include at
least one Dynamic emotion or feeling
word it's the feelings that provide the
fuel that motivate you and get you to
take the action to get where you want to
go and finally make affirmations for
yourself not for others now here's an
example of an affirmation following
these guidelines
I am joyfully driving my new red Porsche
Carrera convertible down the Pacific
Coast Highway in Malibu or if you're
more ecologically minded you can make
that a new Tesla
or you can use the following simple
formula it's really simple form it
always works I am so happy and grateful
that I am now and then you fill in the
blank an example would be I am so happy
and grateful that I'm now earning 150
000 a year
or I'm so happy and grateful that I'm
now celebrating having achieved my ideal
weight of 140 pounds
one of my most famous affirmations is I
am enjoying living in my beautiful
beachfront Villa on the Kaanapali coast
of Maui or somewhere better I started
writing that affirmation in 1989 and in
2011 that's right 22 years later I had
something better you can see the picture
of the House of Maui it's amazing now
make sure to take five to ten minutes
every day to repeat your affirmations
preferably out loud with high energy and
enthusiasm now the best times are in the
early morning when you first wake up and
at night right before you go to bed
because that's when your mind is most
relaxed and most able to take that input
in deeply rule number five is practice
visualization with Brian Tracy there are
four parts of visualization that you can
learn and practice to assure that you
use this incredible power to its best
Advantage all the days of your life
now the first aspect of visualization is
called frequency this refers to the
number of times that you visualize a
particular goal as achieved of yourself
performing in an excellent way in a
particular event or circumstance repeat
a clear mental picture of your very best
performance or resolve the more rapidly
it will appear as part of your reality
the second element of visualization is
the duration of the mental image the
length of time that you can hold the
picture in your mind each time you
replay it
when you deeply relax you can often hold
a mental picture of yourself performing
at your best for several seconds and
then longer for several minutes the
longer you can hold your mental picture
the more deeply it will be impressed
into your subconscious mind and the more
rapidly it will Express itself in your
subsequent performance
the third element of visualization is
vividness
there seems to be a direct relationship
between how clearly you can see your
desired goal or result in your mind and
how quickly it comes into your reality
this element of visualization is what
explains the powers of the Law of
Attraction and the law of Correspondence
the vividness of your desire directly
determines how quickly it materializes
in the world around you
here's an interesting point when you set
a new goal for yourself your image or
picture of this goal will usually be
vague and fuzzy but the more often you
write it and review it and repeat it
mentally the clearer it becomes for you
eventually it becomes crystal clear at
that point the goal will suddenly appear
in your world exactly as you imagined it
now the fourth element of visualization
is intensity
the amount of emotion that you attach to
your visual image in reality this is the
most important and Powerful part of the
visualization process
sometimes if your emotion is intense
enough and your visual image is clear
enough your goal will immediately come
true
of course the elements of frequency
duration vividness and intensity can
help you or hurt you
like nature the power of visualization
is neutral
like a two-edged sword you can cut in
either direction it can either make you
a success or make you a failure
visualization brings you whatever you
vividly and intensely imagine
whether good or bad
continually feed your mind with clear
exciting emotional pictures remember
your imagination is your preview of
life's Coming Attractions and rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is write your vision
with Steve Harvey I'm about to tell you
two things now listen to me
what I'm about to tell you this is for
Spiritual people only
if you're not a spiritual person this
ain't for you if you don't believe in
God this ain't going to do nothing for
you
but I didn't know you was coming so
I have no other version
this is only people who have a faith you
ain't got to be no like born again
Christian or nothing like that you I
just you've got to know that God is God
if you understand that I can help you
from here
I'm gonna give you two things that can
change your life
it's two scriptures that change my
entire life it's very simple the cold
thing about what I'm going to tell you
is anybody can do it
this is what I'm gonna tell you see I'm
not going to talk to you about no
education because I ain't got one I
flunked out of school
I had a severe stuttering problem I
couldn't talk outside my house I ain't
do well in school ever
I ended up flunking out of school I'm on
my third marriage I lost everything I've
owned twice I've been homeless and lived
in a car for three years I'm gonna tell
you what I know this ain't no fancy rich
boy answer no theories no no you ain't
gotta buy no program to do this you
ain't got to go sign up I'm telling you
right now
what I'm fixing to tell you if you apply
it right now can change your existence
because everybody I know want to be
happy everybody I know want to be
successful if you don't want them two
things there's something wrong with you
anyway
so now here there is a scripture that
I'm gonna give you it's a very small
scripture it's very short I don't even
know where it is in the Bible
somebody probably know it if I say it
but I'm gonna give it to you this
scripture changed my life you have not
cause you ask not
you have any idea how major those words
are for you
you have not cause you asked not
[Music]
simple scripture but it's in your Bible
it ain't just in rich people's Bible
it's in the same copy you got
you have not cause you asked not
this is the truest statement you'll hear
me say today because it's true most
people don't have the life of their
dreams cause you don't ask God for the
life of your dreams you've been trying
to figure it out and handle it yourself
well how that's working out for you
you know how hard that is to do man
because I did it
I did it for 30 some years
I tried to figure it out myself
man all the simple scripture says you
have not cause you asked not if you up
your ass he automatically UPS his guilt
you're his child God created you he made
you you ain't just here by no accident
you ain't here cause of your mama and
daddy where your Mom and Daddy come from
somebody somebody started this whole
thing God created you
he gave you these little simple things
you could do you have not cost your ass
not second reason people don't have what
they want and be through it
they don't have it written down
this is a very very important piece to
success it's a principle of success
every wealthy person knows this
I don't know nobody wealthy don't have a
vision board I don't know nobody wealthy
don't have any stuff written on a piece
of paper I don't know nobody I know a
lot of people doing good
we have discussed it at Great Lengths
they've showed me some of their vision
boards that well I had to go back and
change mine I went whoa whoa whoa but
you got to have a vision board that's
got to be written down you know why
because that's the scripture too Rebecca
two and two go I know where this one at
Rebecca two and two go home and read
that one it says write the vision and
make it plain so that He who reads it
will run to it and even though it's
Terry that means take a long time wait
for it for surely it will come at an
appointed time
man
I'm telling you real now
what I'm telling you works to say no
magic trick
if you up your ass and you write
everything you want from God on a piece
of paper now here's the exercise I want
you to do this is going to trip you out
write everything you want from God on a
piece of paper be as detailed as you can
write it down the object for you is to
write down 300 things
because I know 300 things that you could
use
it's going to be hard for you when you
get to number 75 you're gonna get stuck
because your mind isn't conditioned to
think way out there so you're gonna try
to stay in your little list but I want
you to just open up your imagination if
you're gonna have anything you want it
put it on piece of paper anything how
many cards what kind of car what color
why you want your next house to be do
you want a summer home why you want to
travel to how about you on the bank how
much would you like to have to retire
what you want to leave for your
grandkids how much would you like to
give all your siblings would you like to
one day walk in in there and just give
all your family a check put everything
you want on a piece of paper do not stop
until you have 300 things
it's gonna take you a while I'm telling
you when you get to 75 you your brain
gonna lock up
but keep writing it down but every
morning read your list I don't want you
watching TV at night I want you to read
your list unless it's Family Feud other
than that I just
no but seriously take five minutes and
read your list every night every morning
one year from today
one wait one year from today
and take a pin out and go down on your
list and check off
anything that has happened for you
that's on that list
listen to me if you do that in faith if
you read your list with the expectation
that God is going to do some great
things for you at the end of one year
you will be stunned absolutely stunned
at how much stuff comes off that list I
promise you at least 30 things will be
off that list
at minimum 10 of your listing come true
you know how I know because I know a lot
of people that have done it but you know
how I really know because I did it
when I opened up my phone I wish I had
it my phone is my vision board my phone
ain't got pitching no damn dog on it no
Sunset none of that all of my computers
have my vision board on it every iPad
tablet I got laptop when I put it I have
my vision board on it because that's the
signal I'm sending to God that I believe
this is what you're gonna do for me
you'll be I take stuff I got to get a
new vision board now because it's a lot
of stuff off that vision board that I
put on that a year ago or two years ago
that then came true I'm telling you
y'all this how this work you have not
caused your ass not and write the vision
and make it plain you do them two things
starting today write your list read it
every morning every night one year check
it off you'll be stunned I dare you to
try that watch and see what God do
I think one of my first things in
failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting wasn't
mated response
saying your application will not go any
further
I can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a interaction with me they
just saw my name they saw I'd been a
monk for three years that resume is
useless I mean what's your transferable
skills like sitting in silence surprise
surprise no one wants to hire a monk and
so they rejected you but that's not
personal because they didn't meet me in
person but what if they had me right so
that's the first thing the first step is
don't take all fear failure I'll give an
example me and you we've reached out to
countless guests to be on our podcast
we'll say no all the time we're saying
all the time but if I don't hear a no
from the guest directly that's not a no
like someone's team can say no someone's
assistant can say no someone's PR team
can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know no Jay you're
horrible you suck like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah how do you
deal with that type of so I've had you
say this I've said a couple of times and
I'm sure it's been repeated a bunch of
times around how I genuinely believe
failure has feedback feedback and and so
for me it's like failure has the ability
to actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove what others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you were
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah and I think a lot of people can do
that in life but we're so afraid to like
go on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in an agreement that he is
one of the best players to be playing
and they keep losing they need to make
the fight they didn't make the finals
they lost and then they realized they
need to get the team and they need to
find their I think they're bringing
Dennis Rodman and then they start
bringing in all these other players that
strengthen whereas if they would have
just said oh we got the best player in
the world we just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am a failure
have you ever spent any time wondering
how does everything happen how does
everything happen why does the night
follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
in fact in some places it does
but
I spent a lot of time thinking about
this
after times it almost drives me crazy
but like right outside of my studio here
is a Japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the bud Chrome and leaves pop
out and the leaves generally in the
spring are a very deep greeny Brown
they're not a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're the
most beautiful it is the most beautiful
tree and it's right outside in my studio
I'm sitting here in my desk and
the cameras around me but out there is
that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
Every Spring there are greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the faux and greeny brown in the spring
think about it did you ever wonder
why the tide goes way out the tide comes
way back in
I spent some time in the Navy in Canada
I was down on the East Coast for a while
and I was near the Bay of Fundy do you
know the Bay of Fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same upper on Prince George on the West
Coast
you go onto a ship and you might be
walking up a plank just right straight
up and you go off the ship sometimes
you're going right down that ship goes
way up in the air and it comes way down
very high very low tide now some place
the Tide's not very big they do have a
tide but not too high not too low
why is it so different one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer if the
grass just you know just stayed at a
certain length you wouldn't have to cut
it but it would always look pretty
you know
do you ever think about this do you know
that everything in this universe happens
in an exact way
and exactly not by chance but in an
exact way
when John Kennedy the president of the
United States acted as Dr Warner Von
Braun who was the master mind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring them back
safely to Earth Ron Brown answered him
in five words the will to do it that's
it the will to do it
he knew he didn't have to know how to do
it he knew he had to learn how to do it
but you didn't have to know to make up
your mind you were going to do it now
why did he say that because he
understands the laws
if I'm gone one time said after years of
studying the spectacular Mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of God and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise that we don't even have any
difficulty building spaceship we send
people to the moon and we can kind The
Landing with the Precision of a fraction
of a second
now he said these lies must have been
set by someone I see the laws as God's
modus operandi but I'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law when
you and I get in harmony with the law
now we do that odds are pretty good we
should understand them but when we get
in harmony with the law then I'm going
to tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them I'm going to
go shock yourself with the good you can
do now I've been doing that for the last
58 years I'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but I don't
understand them as well as I want to or
would like to
but I'm going to study a little more
today you know I get my trusty book out
here I'll have to talk to you about this
book uh that'll be another time
study the laws find out what they write
what they're like what are the laws and
then study them
you know when you speak about the
neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
think about
Frozen circuits
Frozen circuits are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no
and that you keep doing it enough times
it's no longer conscious that you're
holding a grudge it's no longer
conscious
that you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody is
that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still
and so then the person says I'm not that
person and you say oh no I know I just
had this event in my past and I'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it it's just how do we
overcome it
so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere no time and the identity and the
personality is gone which energy is
going to move Scott to it's going to
follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold the grudge
are you with me still yes so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still yeah so then from
a Quantum perspective you are actually
as a creator of reality holding yourself
hostage because of that person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience and you have an
energetic Bond that's connecting you to
them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that energetic
agreement is are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change in your
emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start lowering the
volume to that emotion and the body
starts liberating energy and you're
calling your energy back to you because
the lower the volume of the emotion the
less you're going to pay attention to
that person there comes a moment where
there's a snap there's a release the
energy is broken and once it's broken
now all of a sudden you free yourself
and you free them and this has happened
to me in my life that people show up 10
years later completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because they had transformed and
and I let them go
so then
forgiveness
from a Quantum perspective in a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
that's all it is and when you start
getting happy with yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body
the bodies start getting a lift of
energy once it makes it's here now
you're going to see that track sending
in energy to the brain the heart acts as
an amplifier to boost the brain are you
with me still
so then once the Energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more love then you feel The Grudge
so then you think
why would I want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation and oxytocin
then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites as fear and
it lowers the volume to fear and anxiety
it shuts the lights out for aggression
and anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it's
it takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like I don't want to forgive him yet
halfway forgive them
and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and she had severe severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
came to our event in
in Tacoma Washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
Oneness
and and that frequency had a message for
her and it said and she was an
incredible Bliss when this happened
I sent four Angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her tariffs
that was the end of her night she
couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was isolated
one moment the Divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy move right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for now she's
healed she's healthy she's happy and
she's on with a new life she's born
again my mother would love this she's
born again in the same life reborn in
the same way didn't pass to a birth
canal for it
she just was born again in the same life
she got a new lease in one instant that
energy was carrying a message and it
made its way all the way into the body
and the Bliss and the joy and the
Gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried would
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness
that's the Divine having its way with
you just give yourself permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
unless that you practice love you're
never going to think that you deserve
the things that you want right so tell
the story
okay so I'm probably gonna I mean
I'll shorten it so this the bottom line
is that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is I walked in and I immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a Vermont
landscape and I was drawn into it
immediately like I was no longer in that
restaurant I was standing in that field
I could feel that breeze I'd never ever
had an experience like that with a
painting if you ever had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean yeah my sense
was that this is very atypical for you
very
so I
kind of lost it the the the restaurant
was quiet and then
I leaned back and suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm gonna own
this painting someday it just that was
what was right there and I looked at the
price and said like three thousand
dollars I'm like not today and I went
back and I sat down and that was it but
the painting never left my mind you see
there's something called The zygon Arc
effect I always say it wrong but it's
like there's a checklist in your brain
that when you have a moment where you're
like this is important your brain puts
it on a checklist yeah it's like a notch
yes a notch happens and now your brain
as part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember
so uh bottom line is uh I always thought
about that painting
years go by
whenever somebody would say Vermont I'd
think of the painting
I don't know why I can't explain it
never wanted a painting before was not
an art student it's going to last like
you're out collecting Arts no no no and
so I you know fast forward the story 10
years and my uh Chris and I are engaged
and we're going to go up to Vermont to
see the leaves and immediately I'm like
we got to go to Simon Pierce I got to
show you the painting so we pull up to
the mill and we walk in and right in
front there is Boom a painting by the
same artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh
my God it's here and we race all around
the place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works Chris was more
disappointed than I was I literally
turned to him and said it's okay dude
like it'd be weird if we're still here
after 10 years I'm gonna track this
thing down I actually said to him you
know what's going to happen Chris
I'm gonna be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate Lobby of some building
and I'm gonna have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but I'm gonna own this thing
I'm Mission yes so a couple years pass
and
um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had what
500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the time
with our first kid
I should have bought a crib or stools
but for whatever reason the zeigon arc
effect takes over and I'm like the
painting so I call the mill and I get
this guy on the phone I'm like uh you
know I want to buy a kale Shepherd piece
and I said could you send me Polaroids
and he's like sure and I tell him the
budget and he goes I'll send you
Polaroids of some of her smaller things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so I
I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and I describe the painting I'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but I bet Gail
will know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail he's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days I paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving Chris crazy because I felt like
what am I going to say to her and I must
be a weirdo I've been stalking this lady
I've been thinking about her for 10
years I can't afford a painting you know
what who am I to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally Chris is like would you call
her I'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was amazing
and then
um I said by the way there was this one
painting and I go and I explain this
painting there's a stand of poplar trees
down the center and a big mountain
Escape behind it and this beautiful blue
Vermont sky and geese flying in
formation overhead and
I could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line
and she said you know Mel I've done so
many large-scale
uh paintings over the years I'd hate to
mistake the one you're talking about but
I'll tell you what
if my husband and I meet you and Chris
at the Mill at Simon Pierce and we'll
walk all around and have lunch and I'll
tell you the stories behind every
painting and if you don't see what you
like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal
so a month passes we go up to the mill I
walk in we meet each other she's amazing
she's like twice our age just an
incredibly cool lady she's walking
around as we're walking around looking
at these paintings Rich I've got I'm
like eight months pregnant I'm realizing
these are ten times the amount of money
that I have
I
I can't afford this
like I don't I don't have this kind of
money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that imposter syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell you
um
she said there's only been two times in
my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
peace
and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in there in the center
of this massive kind of Barn Studio
space is an easel with a painting taped
up with painters tape on it and it was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was
standing before that painting in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there I was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then I realized oh my God I can't
afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing
and he kind of leans over and goes hey
Gail how much for the big one and she
said um
Mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when I was making it 11 years
ago I was making it for her
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book
um this is the galley though right so
wait is it in the is it I think so yeah
yeah and
um it's a reminder every day that your
mind is designed to help you get what
you want
I never stop believing
that I could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you
there is extraordinary science
that proves that your mind has a live
and ever-changing filter a live Network
that changes how it views the world What
it lets in what it blocks out and if you
program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want you ever notice that some
people seem to want to hang on to stuff
that is bothering them they're forever
talking about it they don't want to let
it go they've had a a failure at
something and it's grown they can't get
over it they just can't get over it or
somebody said something nasty to them
they don't want to let it go
do you know what we should do we should
ask ourselves everything that happens is
this serving me
is this serving me and if it's not
serving you get rid of it
you don't want anything in your life
that's not serving you that's not
causing you to grow that's not adding to
the quality of your life
I don't care what it is you will sign
some people they just hold on to bad
stuff they hold on to problems they
don't want to seem to let it go thank
you
and that adds more problems whatever you
focus on grows the only thing that can
grow is the thing you give energy to why
would you hold on to anything that's not
serving you now I want you to think
about this I'm not going to talk about a
lot about this today because I don't
think I have to I just want to let you
know that if you're holding on to
something that does not serve you you
are making a terrible error it's going
to cause all kinds of problems you may
blame other people or other things you
may blame the situation
it's you or the cause of the problem
demanded
told me to pick up this book and read it
Ray Stanford he had a saying he used to
say to me Bob you're the only problem
you'll ever have and you're the only
solution
I think it might have taken me five
years to understand that but I do
understand it
and you know something
I am the only problem I'll ever have and
I Am the Only Solution don't hold on to
anything that is not serving you
rejected
if you know the beautiful part about
having an inductive reasoning Factor
that's the part that chooses thoughts
you can accept or reject the beautiful
part of your mind you can accept or
reject anything that comes into your
world except to reject it it's a choice
don't hold on to anything that is not
serving you consistent action is the
cure-all whatever problem you have
whatever issue you're facing whatever
big life you want to create for yourself
the way to get there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome board
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get to almost two million
subscribers now we're sitting over three
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I had my camera guy and my assistant
and we're filming and the electricity
goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go I guess we can't film like the
first thing that that my camera guy says
is okay well I guess we can't film I
can't film with this like electricity
outage and then fire alarm
fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I
next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making beat is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who are famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you've you have had an idea that you've
loved that you gave up on too soon that
if you just kept doing it this is an
idea that you had maybe three years ago
that if you just found the way to keep
doing it even part-time even on the side
even on the weekends if you just kept at
it you'd be in a different place right
now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and it was your dream and you want it to
happen it's a daily consistent Act
action to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because you're in my
calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday Tuesday is
my YouTube day I always film on Tuesday
I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well we still
work on vacation first off it's not work
like I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
to spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do I take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
as easy as nothing
of course you could take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you
schedule in when you're actually going
to make your dreams happen because
otherwise it's a dream I could say I
want to make YouTube videos but if it
was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too every uh every afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend
2 30. it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sitting in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
just not being intentional that's the
problem if you feel like you got to the
end of the week and you were so busy but
you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you want
in a life whatever your dream life looks
like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos they're
the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what I can make
right now if I'm in a hospital it's
definitely lower than what I can make
out of the hospital but I'm gonna make
the best of what I can make right now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're gonna the next
day wake up and say I'm not I can't do
that I'm not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more I follow through I
follow through I follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and says it's very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're going to do that's why
it's important to create a realistic
calendar don't tell me don't tell
yourself you're going to make 100 videos
a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're going to write 100
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring new people like John asraaf and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of the community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that map your actions to your ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
[Music]
no I'm I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to learn how to
manifest better check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the thing that most of us get
wrong about manifesting is that we have
this big dream like publishing a book or
launching a podcast and all you dream
about is the end that's it you miss the
bridge between Where You Are